libérez la volonté d'entreprendre des
français c'est le message martelé par
arnaud montebourg lors de sa visite à
maurepas
pour cette rencontre le candidat à la
primaire de la gauche a choisi une salle
de sport ouverte il ya quatre ans par
yann la mode
cet entrepreneur a connu des difficultés
pour monter son entreprise
tout comme sammy joola fondateur d'une
start-up dans le domaine médical qui
quand il parle de d'avoir des actions
auprès des banques de sang ce que les
banques soient enfin au service du
peuple
mon service des autres des entrepreneurs
dit oui bien sûr aujourd'hui comme je
l'expliquais j'ai besoin de 2000 euros
pour réparer mon chauffage alors que mes
comptes vont bien que je peux voilà la
banque ne veux pas me prêter alors que
c'est son job
aujourd'hui la boc de prêter l'argent
prêté de l'argent quand on en a ça n'a
pas de sens aujourd'hui on est à se
fixer parce que il n'ya aucune banque
qui prend un risque
alors cessons c'est le métier du monde
de prendre un risque un moment donné
quand on a un projet face à ces
témoignages
arnaud montebourg met en avant certains
points de son programme économique
je propose qu au contraire on libère les
français d'un certain nombre de
contraintes inutiles moins de
réglementations moins de taxes qui
pèsent sur la vie quotidienne
je voudrais aussi créé une banque
d'encouragement au risque qui
cautionnerait le crédit bancaire pour
tous ceux qui n'acceptent pas au
financement sous la signature de l'état
ça permettrait de débloquer le système
bancaire les scrutins de la primaire de
la gauche se dérouleront le 22 et 29
janvier 2017